hello everybody and welcome to another
Python 3 tutorial video with sockets so
in the first video I showed you guys
just the creation of a socket and using
it to request some data then we did a
port scanner then we combined threading
and socket for a threaded socket a
threaded port scanner rather now we're
going to go back to the purpose of
sockets again and we're going to be
talking about sending and receiving data
using sockets so what that's going get
started so I think I'm just going to do
one big ctrl a and delete here and then
we'll go ahead and here we're an import
socket and then we're also going to
import sits for system now we're going
to do a couple of things first for a say
host and host is just going to be blank
for now it's sort of like arbitrary
basically just means that you're willing
to accept or it's going to be like all
interfaces pretty much then supports we
can specify any port that we want for
this let's just do five five five five
you could put almost anything in there
that you want but we'll be using five
five five five so now what we want to do
is we're going to say s equals socket
socket this should be pretty darn
familiar by now socket dot AF underscore
I
oops unit I knit and then socket dot
sock underscore stream like that again
just the address family in sock stream
so we can use the internet not UDP mixed
at this point we've created a socket now
we're ready to do is we want to bind
this socket so let's say try s bind and
this has to be again a tuple so we're
going to say host and port so we bind
that and then accept and really the only
exception we want to accept here is a
sake
error except socket error as e and then
if we get that we're going to print
string e so what was that error let's
just print it out now at this point
we've bound the socket and now we can do
is we can go S dot listen and then in
here you put a parameter we're going to
put five and basically what this
parameter does is it it's kind of like a
queue or it is a queue and it's
basically how many incoming connections
will be fit into queue before we turn
the connection away because we have too
many so that's what we're going to be
doing so we're to be listening on port
5555 and now we will be able to make a
connection to it so let's do the
following so we're going to go
connection address equals s dot accepts
and then we can actually go ahead and
like we can print out some information
on the connections so we can go like
this we can say print connected to : and
we'll do plus a ddr4 address 0 and then
we'll do another plus
this will be there and then plus a ddr1
and actually let's string one and that
should do it for us so now we should be
able to run this first let's see if we
get any air running it does not look
like we did so we're running and we're
waiting for a connection now what you
can do is come over to your command
exe or if you're in bash and use the
following command
so you could say telnet um and then
localhost five five five five hit enter
and there might be a couple of can't
speak couple of trouble for some of you
guys but first of all this works we've
we've got that hey we made this
connection first of all the connection
is over at this point there's not really
a retaining any connection but anyway
you can see that we were able to make
that connection it was listening and it
connected and received some information
from the person who connected to it now
if you're on Windows and you type telnet
and it says telnet does not exit or that
command is you know doesn't exist you go
to you know start control panel bring
that down here you're going to want to
go to programs and then over programs
and features turn Windows Features on or
off click on that and then wait while
this makes a list and come on down to
telnet client you'll want to make sure
that box
helmut client telnet client is checked
and then telnet will work on your
machine similarly if you're on another
machine you know like if you're on Linux
or something might not have telnet I'm
athle installed so sudo apt-get install
telnet and then you'll be able to use
telnet okay so that should cover it if
you guys have any questions or comments
getting this to work
feel free leave them below you should be
able to work for you as soon as you
install telnet so anyways that's it as
always thanks for watching thanks for
all the support subscriptions and until
the next video where we keep that
connection open we do a little bit
better
listening and we do some cool stuff so
stay tuned for that